antes de empezar voy a haceros un
anuncio como sabéis españa ha vivido
todo un terremoto político durante esta
semana del 11 de marzo los dos partidos
que hasta ahora formaban el bloque de
centroderecha en españa han roto y no
con un divorcio tranquilo precisamente
si queréis leer nuestro análisis sobre
este tema lo encontraréis en exclusiva
en latam polític a partir del viernes 12
de marzo como ya sabéis la tan política
es nuestra miss letter sobre
latinoamérica por sólo cinco dólares al
mes recibiréis en vuestro email tres
boletines con el mejor análisis político
cada semana recordad también que las
primeras dos semanas son gratuitas así
que no os lo penséis más entrada en
latam polític puntocom y registrados y
ahora vamos con nuestra historia de hoy
[Aplausos]
[Música]
ah
queridos amigos si os preguntara sobre
qué pensáis acerca de lo que se conoce
como el estado del bienestar esto es de
los servicios públicos en china estoy
prácticamente seguro de que tendríamos
dos opiniones mayoritarias unos
seguramente pensaréis que debe de ser un
estado del bienestar enorme súper
asistencialista con un montón de
coberturas y de cosas gratuitas
cubiertas por el estado al fin y al cabo
china es en teoría un país socialista
pero otros quizás respondiese es que
todo lo contrario que es seguramente en
el 'gigante asiático' de todas estas
cosas prácticamente nada de nada que
hablamos de un país que se centra
obsesivamente en reducir los costes
laborales y que por muy socialista que
sea a la hora de la verdad el trabajador
no tiene más estatus que el de una
máquina de producción pues a todos los
que penséis de una de estas dos maneras
lamento deciros que estáis ambos
equivocados
la idea que tenemos actualmente de
estado de bienestar es decir una serie
de coberturas y seguros sociales pagados
total o parcialmente por el estado no
existido en china hasta los años 90
inicialmente empezó siendo solo un
experimento a nivel local de hecho en el
país de los tres reyes la figura del
estado como garante de una protección
social mínima es algo reciente y no se
parece ni a los sistemas europeos ni
tampoco a los del este de asia es más si
tuviéramos que establecer una
comparación quizás uno de los sistemas
más parecidos sería paradójicamente el
de eeuu
sí sí tal cual como lo escucháis ahora
bien como es exactamente el estado de
bienestar de la república popular china
cómo ha evolucionado a lo largo de las
últimas décadas pues para responder a
estas preguntas queridos amigos y amigas
lo primero es empezar como no por el
principio así que si esta vez también
nos toca decir eso de vamos a ver un
poquito de historia
un sistema en constante evolución
el estado de bienestar chino lo vamos a
llamar así aunque el estado de bienestar
estado bienestar tal y como todos lo
conocemos no existió hasta los 90 pues
se podría decir que ha pasado por tres
periodos al primero que estuvo en vigor
entre los años 1949 1978 se le conoce
como el de la planificación central y es
el que caracterizó las políticas
sociales de mao tse tung al segundo se
le suele llamar como el del pro
crecimiento económico y se extiende
desde 1938 hasta 2003 y el tercero y
actual es conocido como el de la armonía
social ahora bien que hay detrás de
estos rimbombantes nombres pues veréis
el primero el de la planificación
central fue un sistema pseudo
asistencialista inspirado en la unión
soviética como parte fundamental en la
construcción de una economía socialista
de esta forma como el desempleo se
consideraba como una especie de defecto
del capitalismo el régimen asignaba un
empleo a todos los chinos sanos en edad
de trabajar un empleo vitalicio en
empresas y agencias estatales
departamentos gubernamentales granjas
colectivas etcétera etcétera
estas unidades de trabajo recibieron el
nombre de dan way y se organizaban bajo
la fórmula de empresas estatales o
cooperativas en torno a ella se organizó
una especie de mini estado de bienestar
autosuficiente que se componía de tres
elementos principales la permanencia
vitalicia en el empleo conocida como
cuenco de arroz de hierro un salario
igualitario y un paquete de asistencia
social esto último estaba gestionado
directamente por los dan ways y
proporcionaba a los trabajadores de la
unidad una vivienda acceso a educación
sanidad tiendas y otros servicios
claro que un momento porque todo esto
puede sonar más o menos bonito pero
tened en cuenta que hablamos de una
china donde el 89 por ciento de la gente
vivía en zonas rurales extremadamente
pobres un país donde por no haber no
había ni siquiera comida suficiente para
todos así que la calidad de estos
servicios pues ya os podéis imaginar que
dejaba bastante pero bastante que desear
además el hecho de que se proporcionara
trabajo vitalicio vivienda y una serie
de servicios sociales ligados al dan way
no era para nada algo altruista de esta
forma es como el régimen maoísta se
aseguraba gracias también al sistema
hukou tener controlado donde vivía y en
que trabajaba la población y no sólo eso
el hukou le daba al régimen la capacidad
de mover a enormes masas de mano de obra
desde el campo hasta las ciudades para
satisfacer las necesidades de la
industria un sector que mao estaba
potenciando a imagen y semejanza de los
planes quinquenales soviéticos
[Música]
el hukou es el peculiar sistema de
registro de familias chino y aunque ha
evolucionado algo en la práctica siempre
ha servido para establecer una enorme
rigidez para por ejemplo mudarse por
decisión propia del campo a la ciudad
además de ligar los servicios sociales
al lugar de nacimiento en vez de a todo
el territorio del país o al sitio en el
que se trabaja es decir a pesar de ser
ciudadano chino en la práctica puede que
tengas un derecho a sanidad o educación
o desempleo o una pensión en un lugar
pero no en otro algo que ha afectado y
sigue afectando muchísimo a los
trabajadores que emigran del campo a las
urbes
[Música]
aunque sobre todo esto ya hablaremos un
poquito más adelante el caso es que para
1978 china ya había sufrido varias
crisis económicas y políticas y además
estaba quedando muy pero que muy atrás
respecto a los tigres asiáticos hong
kong taiwán singapur y corea del sur y
justo ese año tal y como ya os contamos
en un vídeo que os dejo la descripción
una serie de políticos reformistas se
hicieron con el poder encabezados por
deng xiaoping y si además de realizar
las famosas reformas hacia el
capitalismo de estado o hacia una
especie de socialismo de mercado
llamarlo como queráis también
modificaron el sistema de prestaciones
sociales que simple y llanamente ya no
encajaba con el nuevo sistema que se iba
a poner en pie
[Música]
con el desmantelamiento de las
estructuras colectivas tras las reformas
económicas la protección social para los
campesinos desapareció e incluidas las
antiguas cooperativas sanitarias la
mayor parte de las clínicas rurales
pasaron a ser privadas y mucha gente del
campo de bajos recursos se quedó sin
capacidad de acceder incluso a la
atención sanitaria en las ciudades la
política del pleno empleo forzoso se
reemplazó en 1986 por contratos
individuales y las empresas fueron
liberadas de sus obligaciones
asistenciales esto hizo un primer
momento muchos trabajadores sobrantes
fueran despedidos y quedaran totalmente
expuestos incrementando así la pobreza
urbana además la idea de emaús de que el
crecimiento económico dependía
directamente del crecimiento demográfico
empeoró y dificultó mucho esta
transición porque de repente sobraba
muchísimo capital humano lo que
inmediatamente trató de corregirse con
políticas como la del icónico
establecida en 1979
[Música]
el caso es que para finales de los 80 el
régimen llevaba ya demasiados años
centrado en las reformas políticas
internas dejando un poquito de lado la
situación social de una población que no
lo había pasado bien antes y que ahora
pues lo estaban pasando incluso peor con
todos los cambios que se estaban
poniendo en marcha ya sabéis los cambios
suelen conllevar un período de
transición especialmente cuando son
cambios muy graduales y muy lentos pero
que tienen mucha trascendencia
[Música]
así que claro de esta forma el malestar
social las huelgas y el riesgo de
colapso político que estaban suponiendo
las reformas hacia el capitalismo de
estado que acaban de ponerse en marcha
forzó al gobierno a diseñar un nuevo
sistema esencial con una visión simple y
llanamente pragmática digamos que la
percepción política mayoritaria era que
si no se daba la respuesta lo antes
posible a todas estas necesidades
sociales y la violencia la delincuencia
y la conflictividad aumentaban no sólo
las reformas podrían llegar al es el
carril ar sino que el propio poder del
partido comunista chino podría venirse
abajo así que para finales de los 80 y
principios de los 90 el estado dejó de
centrarse en las reformas políticas y
empezó a dar prioridad a la cuestión de
la protección social claro que de una
forma muy pero que muy distinta a los
que estáis acostumbrados quienes nos
estáis viendo desde la vieja europa
en ese momento se establece un sistema
de seguridad social cuya intención era
reducir la carga asistencial de los than
ways de modo que junto a las empresas
los empleados y el estado compartirán
también los costes lo que por sí mismo
también ayudaría a impulsar la
competitividad de las corporaciones
chinas a finales de 1991 se creó en
shanghai primero y luego en 1995 a nivel
nacional un fondo de previsión para la
vivienda un fondo de ahorro forzoso que
tenía el objetivo de facilitar que las
personas accedieran a una vivienda
asimismo en esta misma línea también se
establecieron créditos a bajos intereses
para los préstamos hipotecarios luego
con la ley laboral de 1994 se introdujo
un nuevo marco de estado de bienestar
que incluyó entre otras cosas un sistema
de subsidios públicos para los más
pobres un seguro social o cuenta de
ahorro obligatorio e individuales para
complementar el sistema público de
pensiones
como veis todos estos aumentos en las
coberturas sociales en china son
relativamente muy recientes ya que buena
parte del sistema actual se construyó en
los años 90 sin embargo lo cierto es que
todas estas reformas a pesar de su
reducido alcance jugaron un papel
esencial tanto a la hora de consolidar
el poder del partido comunista como de
impulsar y asentar a la clase media
ahora bien llegamos hasta aquí y seguro
que muchos de vosotros os estaréis
preguntando vale vale enrique todo esto
está muy bien pero cómo es exactamente
ahora el sistema de bienestar chino que
es lo que queda del pasado y cómo
funciona en el presente pues bien
veámoslo
[Música]
no tan socialistas como pensabas seamos
sinceros de escribir el sistema de
bienestar chino y es una tarea titánica
porque más que un sistema es un sistema
de sistemas con diferentes coberturas
beneficios y privilegios en función de
donde vivas o en que trabajes pero para
simplificarlo podemos decir que el
sistema actual está organizado en tres
pilares la asistencia social el seguro
social y los servicios de bienestar
en primer lugar la asistencia social es
la ayuda directa a las personas más
pobres y su principal exponente es la
garantía de subsistencia mínima una
especie de ingreso mínimo en dinero que
gestionan las autoridades locales y que
es distinto según el lugar donde se vive
una ayuda de la que por cierto están
excluidos la mayoría de los trabajadores
migrantes chinos de zonas rurales que se
van a otros sitios a trabajar como por
ejemplo las ciudades
[Música]
en segundo lugar tenemos el seguro
social que es todo un rompecabezas
dificilísimo de gestionar y que está en
el punto de mira del gobierno central
por sucesivos escándalos de corrupción y
la falta de control de los fondos y los
beneficiarios este sistema está
compuesto de varios seguros y pensiones
por ejemplo tenemos la pensión básica de
jubilación que cubra hasta el 60% del
sueldo que se cobraba trabajando siempre
que se hubiera cotizado más de 15 años
es un sistema gradual es decir se has
cotizado 15 años recibes en torno al 15
por ciento de tu antiguo salario como
pensión y por cada año cotizado este
porcentaje aumenta un 1% este sistema de
pensiones se financia a través de
cotizaciones por parte de los empleados
y del empleador luego hay un sistema
paralelo de pensiones rurales similar al
sistema empresarial pero con un subsidio
colectivo del gobierno que sustituye a
la cotización del empleador estas
pensiones además son más bajas que las
del sistema empresarial
[Música]
pero esto no termina aquí también hay
mucha tela que cortar con el tema del
seguro médico otro auténtico galimatías
este seguro está en realidad compuesto
por tres distintos y eso como mínimo
para los empleados urbanos de empresas
para otros trabajadores urbanos y el de
los trabajadores de las cooperativas
rurales este último creado en 2003 es
voluntario y ha permitido dar acceso a
la sanidad al 97% de la población del
campo el seguro médico también se paga
ante el trabajador y el empleador pero
quizás la característica más
sorprendente para muchos de vosotros es
que en china no existe la sanidad
universal y gratuita no al menos en la
forma en la que se existen en algunos
países por ejemplo de la vieja europa
[Música]
de hecho a pesar de estar cubierto por
el seguro médico existe un copago
sanitario por el que el seguro médico
público solo cubre alrededor del 60 por
ciento de los costes en el mejor de los
casos además los centros médicos no
tienen por qué ser públicos de hecho
cada vez es más extensa la red de
hospitales y clínicas privadas en toda
china luego por supuesto también hay
seguros médicos privados que son cada
vez más habituales y que suelen servir
pues como complemento para mejorar la
calidad asistencial y cubrir la parte
del copago que no está subvencionada por
el seguro estatal y si las mujeres aquí
también tienen un seguro de maternidad
con un permiso de 98 días pagados al
100% por los empleadores y que compensa
a la pérdida de ingresos salariales
durante la baja maternal pero avancemos
en china- también hay un seguro de
desempleo financiado como en la mayoría
de los países entre el trabajador y el
empleador un seguro que cubre hasta 24
meses con una ayuda básica y que según
el sitio puede incluir o no también
gastos médicos
y ya para terminar está el tercer pilar
que es el de los servicios de bienestar
orientados a los más pobres los
huérfanos discapacitados y ancianos más
desfavorecidos pues bien estos son en
teoría los pilares del sistema de
bienestar que pone sobre la mesa al
gobierno chino como veis es un sistema
mucho más laxo y externalizado de lo que
podríamos pensar en un país
supuestamente socialista y no sólo eso
porque ya sabéis que una cosa es la
teoría y otra muy distinta la práctica
[Música]
un modelo plagado de agujeros
a ver el sistema de bienestar chino si
atendemos al menos a lo que podríamos
pensar de un sistema social público en
un país que quiere ser algo así como el
adalid de la superación social del
capitalismo pues tiene dos grandes
problemas todavía cubre demasiada poca
gente y es muy discriminatorio fijaos
por ejemplo en este gráfico como veis de
todos los trabajadores urbanos menos del
70% cotizan para la pensión sólo un 44%
lo hace para el seguro de desempleo y
apenas la mitad para el seguro de salud
pero si esto ya os parece poco fijaos en
lo que ocurre con los trabajadores
migrantes sólo un 22 por ciento cotizan
para la pensión el mismo porcentaje para
el seguro de salud y apenas un raquítico
17% participan en el seguro de desempleo
según datos del propio gobierno chino
pero espera un momento cómo encaja esto
que os estamos contando con titulares
como este más del 95 por ciento de la
población de china tiene seguro médico
básico pues bien lo cierto es que estos
titulares no son mentira pero tampoco
son verdad por ejemplo los trabajadores
migrantes por el hukou en sus zonas
rurales de origen técnicamente están
cubiertos por el sistema médico de
cooperativas rurales
pero no lo están en las zonas urbanas
que es donde viven y trabajan es decir
puede ser verdad que un 95% de la
población china está cubierta por algún
tipo de seguro médico pero el porcentaje
que puede disfrutar de esa cobertura en
el sitio donde trabaja es mucho pero que
mucho menor y ojo porque esto no es algo
que se pueda dejar pasar por alto a
finales de 2019 por ejemplo había casi
300 millones de trabajadores migrantes
chinos que se habían ido del campo a la
ciudad para mejorar su nivel de vida así
que ya os podéis imaginar la cantidad de
gente que se queda fuera del sistema
asistencial del gobierno chino
en otras palabras en torno a una sexta
parte de la población china está
expuesta a unos niveles de precariedad
mayores que los de la población
registrada en jugos urbanos aunque ojo
porque al gobierno le viene muy bien
este dato para mantener por las nubes
unas estadísticas sin necesidad de poner
fondos adicionales al fin y al cabo si
300 millones de personas se han marchado
del campo la ciudad pues no necesitas
proveer infraestructuras sanitarias para
todas esas personas a pesar de que
supuestamente sí que están cubiertas en
sus lugares de origen vamos que estos
tíos conseguirían hacer rentable a
empresas como nicolás aunque fuera
descontando hipotéticos ingresos de
clientes potenciales vetos adversos
pero además del problema del sistema go
que os estamos contando lo cierto es que
la altísima tasa de trabajo informal
empeora mucho este problema y es que
veréis sólo el 35 por ciento de los
trabajadores migrantes de los
trabajadores que han llegado del campo
tienen contratos formales y digamos que
si no tienes un contrato formal pues
quedas excluidos de los servicios
sociales más allá de tu lugar de origen
entendéis el problema bien por su parte
otro de los retos como ya mencionábamos
antes está en la propia gestión del
sistema incluso varias auditorías del
propio gobierno chino confirman que el
sistema bienestar está plagado de
irregularidades
irregularidades como la falta de
cotización de muchas empresas el pago
indebido de prestaciones a personas no
elegibles o la apropiación indebida por
las autoridades locales de fondos del
seguro social para otros menesteres a
pesar de todo el sistema del bienestar
de china según las estadísticas
oficiales tiene superávit aunque eso sí
estas mismas estadísticas muestran que
el sistema especialmente el sistema de
pensiones se enfrenta a un problema
serio de viabilidad por la falta de
acumulación de capital o con otras
palabras aunque existen las cuentas de
ahorro obligatorio individuales en la
práctica el sistema de pensiones
funciona básicamente como un sistema de
reparto por el que las contribuciones de
hoy cubren las necesidades de hoy la
idea inicial era crear un sistema
similar al de chile o singapur donde los
fondos de ahorro obligatorios y las
cotizaciones sociales estuvieran
capitalizadas pero esto no se ha logrado
[Música]
en fin ya lo veis a grandes trazos así
es como se vertebra el estado de
bienestar de la república popular china
un sistema basado en seguros con mucha
presencia de actores privados en la
prestación de los servicios y que en
líneas generales asemeja mucho más al
sistema norteamericano que a las
socialdemocracias europeas un modelo por
cierto muy escaso en prestaciones
públicas y sujeto a muchas limitaciones
que hacen que una buena parte de los
ciudadanos chinos estén de facto
excluidos eso sí el crecimiento
económico que tiene registrado desde
1978 desde ya se pusieron en marcha las
reformas no sólo ha logrado una
increíble reducción de la pobreza y
menor mejora los niveles de vida de las
familias sino que también ha permitido
que se produzcan noticias como estas 25
de febrero de 2021
xi jinping declara que se ha eliminado
la pobreza extrema en china el
presidente chino afirma que 850 millones
de personas han salido de la indigencia
en un logro sin precedentes pero
llegados a este punto turno para ti qué
opinas del actual estado de bienestar
chino te esperabas que iba a ser así o
pensabas que sería todo no sé mucho más
público y estatalizado cuéntanos tus
impresiones por aquí abajo en los
comentarios y ya sabes si te ha gustado
este vídeo no olvides darle a like y
suscribirte a visual político una vez
más muchas gracias por estar ahí un
saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]